each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
alright
and the novel
prices are depressed by traders other
kind those patrol car tire
come on
further
bachata bicycle tire you pump over 100
psi cars or 30
her
so we're very happy to have ten nine
years frequent visitor Microsoft after
today winter and fall winter and
tightness
thank you it's a great pleasure to be
here particularly because much of this
work was done right here at microsoft
research and collaboration with mike
reason Colonel Stengel who was a postdoc
here Jeff Walker who's also a frequent
visitor and men you may know and also
jenga analog there's also been a
frequent visitor here an email so in
order to introduce what I'll be talking
about today I'd like to just make
briefly the point that in condensed
matter physics there what one often
described as the central problem is to
understand different states of matter
that can arise in nature and what I'll
be talking about a little bit of thrust
of this work is trying to understand a
particular class of states of matter and
how do they may be relevant possibly two
problems like 14 kidding now kind of the
simplest and most in many ways most
familiar is basically an elastic medium
okay and this is a simple character
chair which described many states of
matter so if you have an elastic medium
its ground state it's roughly flat you
can imagine ripples on it okay and
because the ground state is breaking the
symmetry which is symmetry under a
translation of the sheet the lower
energy excitations as they get too long
wavelengths are gapless in energy okay
and this is a very useful caricature and
also basically describes magnets or a
large possum Agnes in which the spins in
the Magnar of the small microscopic
magnetic moments point in some
particular direction okay and because a
uniform rotation of all the spins is a
symmetry of the system a slowly varying
rotation very slowly from point to point
cause very little energy okay and this
is often called a broken symmetry state
okay crystal is the same thing in which
can you formally translate the crystal
and so therefore a slowly varying
translation of the different atoms in
the crystal is a low energy excitation
and low energy excitations are important
because they're also what you can
observe at long wavelengths so there are
the things that are going to determine
most macroscopic experiments probing the
properties of basically not any any
matter that one might encounter in daily
life or otherwise now what I'll be
talking about is something that's in
some sense the antithesis or at least a
different possibility from a broken
symmetry state or continuum elastic
medium and these particular states of
matter to topological skates they also
have a useful caricature which is
basically some kind of see of
fluctuating loops okay which I'm drawing
here is kind of a art well not really
hard as my rendition my artistic
rendition of what a sea of fluctuating
loops might look like and the idea again
is that this is a general paradigm for a
particular class of states of matter the
ways in which these loops may arise
microscopically from the underlying
degrees of freedom are various for
instance if you have a model of icing
like spins okay on the triangle lattice
as I've gone on the left here then you
can see that the domain walls between up
and down spins are loops living on a
honeycomb or hexagonal lattice okay I
guess you can't see it so well you see
there are some moves here separating up
from the down spins another way in which
loops might arise microscopically is if
you have a system of spins on a lattice
then one way of understanding spin zero
states is to think of them in terms of
different states which are formed by
forming spin singlets between different
pairs of spin a hops okay so you have
spins living on in this case the square
lattice on each of the
sides of the square lattice and they can
form these bonds like that I've drawn
here with these lines in which the two
spin has informed the spin singlet okay
now to mention one
well I'm actually going to be talking
principally about two dimension ok so I
think that there are three dimensional
animal everything i'm going to say for
some of the one of particular state of
matter that will be talking about does
have a very simple three-dimensional
handle on in which you're still talking
about boobs but most of it i'll be
talking about is in two dimensions
that's a very good question ok so you
can think of a system of spins on a
lattice it may be the case and for many
hamiltonians it is the case that low
energy states are composed of states in
which neighboring spins form singlets
and by then taking any such
configuration of singlets and
superposing it with some reference
configurations with the dotted lines are
you see that you end up with
configurations of loops because some of
which may be kind of microscopic loops
or just lengths to over here so the
point of this is that there are various
ways in which systems of electrons or
spins or what have you can have consoled
rains or self organized in such a way
that they're low energy physics is just
best characterized are parametrized in
terms of loops which of course can
fluctuate yet another example here is a
particularly useful one for i'll be
talking about which is you may have a
system of spins such that the up spins
form chains which from connected ethnic
loops and and the other sides which i
haven't drawn in or where the down spend
are a particular model due to alexa
Kataya who is also the postdoc and this
frequent visitor here is on the left us
are on the right side of the slide and
the basic Hamiltonian here is defined as
follows suppose on the raddest that I've
drawn the left I've only drawn in some
up spins over here but let's say that
there's actually a spin on every single
link of this lattice ok we can point up
or down I just haven't bothered in that
picture to draw in the down spins to
avoid clutter now
the hamiltonian that governs these spins
is sum of a number of terms half of
which are terms that are on every vertex
of this lattice in half of which are
terms on every flick at the terms of
vertices are just the product of Sigma
Z's on all the links surrounding that
vertex so it's just a product of plus or
minus ones the phuket term is a product
of the sigma actions on all of the links
around a given flick at so the first
term is just cakes there are four spins
here around the given vertex u
multiplied together so then of those
pins in a sigma z bases are either plus
or minus one corresponding to up or down
you multiply those together okay and you
add up such a term for every vertex of
the lightest there's also placate charm
and AG implicit has four spins and
circling that protect and you multiply
together the sigma axes okay and what
you can observe just from looking at the
first term is that it's a product of
Sigma Z's and the Hamiltonian is such a
term enters the Hamiltonian with a minus
sign and so to minimize energy you
actually want such a turn to have
eigenvalues and I'm 5-1 and eigenvalue 1
occurs and there's an even number of up
spins and an even number of down spins
around any vertex and so that's telling
you that if we're the up spins are is
where you're drawing in loops and any
loop that enters the vertex must also
leave over text so there are in order to
minimize the first terms in the
Hamiltonian their energy this should be
looking at configurations in which the
up spins are connected into connected
clothes notes now
so the basic point of I've been saying
is that in fact many of these kinds of
systems that one encounters in
electronic physics can be thought of in
terms of loops now the loops of course
there's also quantum mechanics here it's
only by introducing quantum mechanics
and any magic can happen and of these
loops are going to base certain quantum
dynamics right so all I've really been
discussing as far as kinematics in a
sense what the basic low energy states
look like they're going to have to obey
some clown dynamics and that dynamics
will see can impose some topological
rules and depending on what those
particular rules are the system may end
up in some stable gap topological phase
a topological state of matter which
haven't defined for you yet exactly what
that means but I will or it may instead
be in a critical point or if one is from
this point of view are lucky you may end
up in a broken symmetry state and stuff
and in this picture excitations are
violations of these rules okay so when I
say quantum dynamics I also mean by
implication of Hamiltonian and so
expectations are localized points at
which the Hamiltonian is taking some
value other than its minimum value one
way of doing this period is the break
loops so you have excitations there are
other types of stations as well but
their excitation which correspond to end
points of these broken loops and the
rules are paid by these loops determined
various properties of these kinds of
excitations including rating statistics
ground state degeneracies and so on ok
now some of this seems a little abstract
but I'll give you a very simple example
which hopefully will make this little
bit clearer this is this model that I
just introduced two slides ago and as we
noted the first term the AIS can go back
and remind you what the Hamiltonian is
the Hamiltonian is again the sum of
terms correspond to vertices and four
cats now the one key observation here is
that in fact the same Ultron is exactly
soluble because every single term in the
sample
Knutson every other term so in that
sense it's it's trivial if you take a
look at so the vertex term is
multiplying these spins over here
scences a vertex and you've also got
applicat term acting on this placate
here and what you see is that a given
flick aetna given vertex can either
share 0 or two spins ok if they share 0
spins and clearly the operators commute
they share two spins and since Sigma X
and Sigma Z and he canoed you get 2
minus x and so again the operator envy
and FP will commute so these operators
all commute with each other ok and
consequently this model is exactly
soluble in the way to solve it is to is
to diagonalize every one of these
operators the Avs should all take eigen
value plus one the FPS it also all take
eigen value plus lon now the meaning of
the first statement that the AV zoltek I
could x plus 1 is clear.its when I said
a few minutes ago is just that you can
think of the ground state you can think
of the states which have lower so maybe
useful exercise is to let j1 be
extremely large so Jay one is much much
larger than j2 and then you can
essentially forget about anything it
doesn't have a V equal plus log right
now those are all states which have up
spins which can be connected to form
sequences of closed loops ok on the
square lattice those loops can actually
intersect that doesn't matter very much
or it's not particularly inconvenient
for the state that I'm about to talk
about four other states may be
inconvenient and one should use a
different lattice like the honeycomb
lattice with this this problem would
arise ok so now if we just focus on
these configurations of loops on the
square lattice then we also have to
diagonalize these operators FP and FP
having eigenvalue 1 imposes the
following relations on the ground
a the way FP axis remember sigma x flips
and up spin to a down spin and a down
spin to an up span ok so if Sigma if FP
act on here's applicat here the acts on
this quick idea will flip these three up
spins into down spins it he'll flip this
gallant fit into the up spin and you end
up with this ok similarly if it FP acts
on configuration like this where you
have four up spins around applicant it
will flip it into a situation like this
in which you have no spin up all the
screens on the you can put header down
and if you have a situation like this
with two up stones here it will flip
these two into down spins and flip these
two incomes friends you have a situation
like this right so the statement that
the ground state is an eigen value under
this operation tells you that the ground
state has to give equal amplitude for
situation like this is for a situation
like this and so on ok or quite simply
and you're consumed you can simply say
the ground state can be viewed as an
equal amplitude superposition of all
possible loop configurations now yes
I see FB is giving a value to
configuration so and if you have some
spins around the foot head that would
give a value which would be well okay so
FP is a product of Sigma access so if
you work in a basis in which Sigma Z is
diagonal which is the implication when I
draw these boot configurations so a
configuration like this has ups up all
these fins are up now FP is a prior to
Sigma X and Sigma X doesn't have a
well-defined value here right so this is
not an eigen value of any of these
signatures nor of their product and so
actually when you act with cigarettes so
you might take this configuration or
this thing transforms into this one
Sigma X act so if Sigma Z in matrix
notation is 1 minus 1 and sigma x is 0 1
1 0 this is in a basis where an up spin
is 10 and a down spin is 0-1
so you should think of Sigma X is a spin
flip operator flips up jumped up and up
to down where Sigma Z is just telling
you 1 or minus 1 now the statement that
I finished with you is that the ground
state can be viewed as an equal
amplitude superposition of all possible
loop configuration but that actually
state requires little care because it
may or may not be correct to use a
singular here depending on the topology
of the underlying manifold because if
you look for instance if the annulus you
put the system on an annulus then in
fact there are two distinguishable
ground states corresponding to even or
odd winding numbers around the origin
and the annulus because this equality
here tells you that in fact winding
numbers are only conserved modulo 2 and
that the ground state will mix let's say
winding number 0 line number two why
number four and so on and similarly with
odd winding numbers but there's no term
in the Hamiltonian that causes mixing of
different one of whining numbers of
different parody so in fact there are
two inequivalent ground states on the
annulus however they also clearly cannot
be distinguished by any local
measurements since the f the f san days
are a complete set of local operators ok
so there's nothing local that
distinguishes these it's only some
topological property namely the even and
odd miss of the winding number that
distinguishes these two states now
that's part of the reason why one would
call this a topological state of matter
it's that you have two distinguishable
you have a gap first of all types
occations so at low energies let's say
you can forget about all the
expectations if you're only doing
experiments that are probing physics
that is to say you only do experiments
involving frequencies less than this gap
energy and you only do experiments at
wavelengths that are long compared to
the relevant length scale
is in this case is actually one lattice
spacing then forget about all
excitations you only have ground states
and the ground state structure of image
in this case is too full depending on
the on the annulus the ground state
structure depends on the topology other
line space and nothing else so in
particular for this particular
Hamiltonian you have ground state to on
the annual issue of ground state for on
the torus your ground state for to the G
of genus G surface ok so there's a
ground state degeneracy that depends on
the topology the manifold number one and
number two these different ground states
are not distinguishable by any local
measurements ok now the second sense in
which this which is related in which
there's topology that arises here is
that when one starts look at the
excitation these excitations are
vertices or flick X at which a I is
equal to minus 1 or FP is equal to minus
1 these correspond to either take a loop
and breaking it ok so you now two end
points or frustrating one of these
poquette's so that FP is minus one
around such applicata and i won't go
through this in detail now but can
certainly come back if later someone's
interested and you can do the exercise
to show that in fact there is
non-trivial braiding associated with
taking one of these types of excitations
around another so the reason that this
is usable so I still haven't given you a
definition I made in the sense that
there's a good definition of a
topological state of topological phases
of matter it would be that the
low-energy effective field theory is a
topological field field meaning the
lower energy effective filter can be
written down without introducing a
metric ok as a practice that's a little
bit perhaps a little bit too abstract
and as a practical matter what it really
means is that you have a ground state
degeneracy which depends on the topology
of the manifold ok and that these
different degenerate ground states are
indistinguishable by local experiments
and that you have excitations which have
non-trivial ratings
Thanks okay now a local perturbation the
reason that this is useful potentially
for quantum computation is that
precisely the statement that these
different equivalent ground States
cannot be distinguished by local
measurements because if you think of the
environment as disrupting your system by
performing a local measurement it can't
distinguish these two different so in
essence the two or whatever few bits or
however you wish to think of the fun of
information those states cannot be where
you don't want to have happen is you
don't want in the middle of a
computation for the environment to
measure whether you're in state 0 or 1
let's say and here it can't so what it
could do for instance is a local
perturbation system could flip a spin ok
but what's most likely to happen to
force is that the spin will flip back
and it will radiate off some energy and
you know in the form of radiation and
the system will heal itself now this is
usually a bad thing because in this
process you'll get a different choir
different phase depending on which state
you were in ok and so you'll get some
key phasing as well this is what's
decoherence is now in this situation
precisely because all local physics is
the same in these two inequivalent
ground states the phases that will be
acquired as well be the same as well
it's only some measurement which can
really distinguish these two states that
could cause them to dekho here and it's
another way of thinking about different
states of matter is the Associated
rigidities so that that come with them
so the continuum elastic medium that
I've mentioned earlier has a rigidity
associated with it has a shear modulus
it has a bending modulus hey solids are
solid right and the reason that they're
solid is because they involve breaking
of translational symmetry well
topological states also have
right right what you can build an
annulus though and you can put you two
built under than multiple punctures
instead of an air nose and actually but
let me come back to your question let me
answer that in more detail with a later
in the talk also so here I mean the kind
of rigidity we have is this rigidity
against local perturbations and that's
where this idea due to Alexei and Mike
and and pioneers in this field of
topologically protected qubits comes
from okay now what I'd like to do is
just briefly mention how much of the
structure that simple model can be
generalized okay so if you consider wave
functions whereas you know usually you
think of in quantum and simple quantum
mechanics as wave functions cybex right
you have an X somewhere which is the
position of a particle and you want to
know what the probability amplitude is
that you are X you just take size of X
norm squared and that's the probability
of particle deposition acts well here
let's say you have a system spin like
we're talking about well you want to
know what let's say the probability or
probability amplitude is for there to be
up spins at certain locations and down
spins and certain other locations right
that may be the kind of thing you want
to know and so there should be a wave
function which tells you that and if you
assume that you're in this low energy
space where J one that I wrote down
before is taken very large that you can
forget about any configurations in which
the up spins don't form up chains then
you can really just restrict your
attention to some multi loops alpha like
I've drawn here and remembering that
these represent the position
the out spins if we're talking about
that model that I was just talking about
in the last few slides or for these
represent the positions locations of
these spin singlet dimers or whatever
the underlying microscopic physics is
the model of hand then this is going to
give you the probability amplitude for
that particular configuration and one
property that these wave functions
should satisfy in any reasonable process
of theories that you would expect to
give rise for topological phase is that
it you can government under smooth
deformations of these loops ok so what a
function takes the same amplifies the
same amplitude there ok ah a second
property that one would like is that if
you have a small contractible loop
somewhere you should be able to erase it
guys to say the wave function should
have almost the same amplitude for a
configuration with or without a small
contractible loop I say almost because
it could get multiplied by a factor of D
which happen to be one in the model that
we just just solved but in general could
be an arbitrary number or you might
imagine that it could be an arbitrary
number you mean at the very least expect
such a relation otherwise it's clear
that you would have infinitely many
ground States even the absence of any
apology so you need a Hamiltonian with
quantum dynamics that at least imposes
some restriction of this form ok now the
final thing is which we have this model
we have some kind of invariance of the
wave function under a quote sir jee
relation which cut and rejoin some loops
so that when two loops can close
together you could cut them and rejoin
them like this ok and again with without
a relation like this the ground state
degeneres are the torah so the annuals
would have been infinite it's only
because of having a relation like this
that we ended up with to fold the
Genesis annulus and for to the geology
NSG manifold and this one too presumably
have some kind of generalization ok and
by generalizing the latter
conditions that will are constructive a
family of topological states of matter
all of which have this kind of
description in terms of quantum loop
gases or fluctuating loops now they're
clearly going to be some consistency
conditions and well let me first say one
other thing which is why do we even care
right why do we even worried about
trying to generalize this we have a
model seems to have this nice feature of
being topologically protected why not
just declare victory and we draw right
now and I'll refrain from being the
August jokes about current political
situation but there are some good
reasons not to just declare victory
withdraw right now which is we do have
topological protection now the problem
with this is that so let's say roughly
speaking these are on the annulus our
two ground States where I've drawn here
something one number zero but by
implication this actually means a linear
superposition is a shorthand for a
linear superposition of all possible
pictures which have even winding number
ok and over here you have a shorthand
for a linear solution superposition of
all possible pictures that have on
winding number ok now it is great
there's this wonderful fact that the
environment is not going to cause the
coherence between these you can set up a
linear superposition or it's not going
to cause one to flip into the other at
least not in the thermodynamic limit it
will be very varied it will be
exponentially difficult for the
environment to cause one why number to
flip it to the other but the flip side
the problem is is that it's also equally
difficult for us to do anything useful
with these ok I mean you want to do
operations you want to switch one to the
other and that's clearly very difficult
here so it's not only topologically
protected from the environment it's also
topological protected from us
and finally how would you even do a
measurement to determine what the final
answer is here that also looks very
difficult so there are a couple of
issues worth pondering here namely that
while we have all this great topological
protection we also maybe have a little
too much at least insofar as trying to
anything useful with this so this is
part this is related to the fact that
what we have here is actually an abelian
state okay in which all that can happen
as a result of rating operations is you
can pick up a phase or something well
you can pick up at most you can pick up
a phase when you take 21 excitation
around another and so actually moves us
to take a look at not a billion states
in which you have more interesting kinds
of transfer that is not a billion
representations of the brave group with
which not states of matter which are
associated with monitor the
representations of a group so that when
you take one excitation on another you
can actually enact some kind of
non-trivial operation on the hilbert
space okay so that's the motivation for
looking at generalizations of this so
this sort of does this does have the job
but by doing half the job actually does
too much and so that's why we are
looking at generalizations but the
generalizations that I'll be talking
about have many features in common with
this very simple model now if you turn
to look at this problem of generalizing
this you immediately see they it's it's
not obvious or at least immediately see
that it's highly constrained problem
because let's say that d is not equal to
1 okay then if you assume that you have
the old surgery relation that we had in
the D equals one case which is the
surgeon relation here then you can see
that you take this curve you
continuously to form into this you can't
apply the surgery relation to get this
and then you use the relation for D that
you have nearly have a contradiction
okay so you can't do it in the most
naive way possible just changing d so
what you have to do is it is change d
you also have to change the circulation
it's clear there's really virtually no
other choice for the surgery relation
you could have had with two lines you're
really only choices were to have a plus
or minus sign here since applying the
surgery relation twice had to get you
back to the same picture so what you
have to do is you net then are required
to look at surgeon relations that
involve three four however many curves
depending on d in fact there's an
important mathematical result here which
is that for almost all d there is really
no consistent circulation and it's only
for very special DS that sir consistent
surgery relations can be found these are
these values d equals two times cosine
of PI over k plus two and they increase
in complexity as you increase dear
increase K so for instance the next one
is d equals square root of two and you
can see that the relation has five terms
and involves taking three curves and
cutting them and rejoining them in
different possible ways that don't
involve lines crossing okay you can also
see that these relations and I will have
some nonzero coefficients inside of them
and the next one is the next value of D
is K equals 3 which is the golden mean
and
and maybe consolidation and I not happen
to prop oh ok yeah i think this thing
just came was the connection
ok
i think i don't know i think i'm gerry
like that no hang on i think this will
work
yeah i think this gorgeous can lose
Oh
okay okay okay yep we're back sorry okay
so um
so you end up with relations like this
now this may not sing to you just yet
but if you think about it for a minute
it's a relation like this which leads to
having non-trivial properties so for
instance supposing now that i have for
excitation of which are the kind of
excitations you make by breaking loops
and you have endpoints now now what you
can see is that i can let's say exchange
excitations two and three in a counter
clockwise manner and i can also exchange
excitations three and four and what
you'll observe is depending on the order
in which i do that i can either go here
and then end up over here or by doing
the opposite order i end up with a
different state so this is why this is
called a knock this is why this is a non
abelian representation the brave group
it's that the order in which you do
these operations braiding operations
matters number one number two you'll
observe that if d or equal to 1 that is
to see if we had that surgery relation
that we have in the simplest type model
then you can apply the surgery relation
right here and you see that this game is
in fact the same as this state or
possibly up to a sign or something like
that okay so similarly do these
exchanging operations and nothing
happens really or nothing much
interesting happens but here this state
is a distinct one this even though
they're locally indistinguishable you
look anywhere locally here is no
difficulties lines are really fluttering
and there's no difference in these two
states but in fact they're linearly
independent okay and so if you have four
quasiparticles at fixed positions then
you actually have multiple linearly
independent states okay and it's in that
that space of multiple linearly
independent states and obviously as you
increase the number of product particles
the number of states increases that's
your playground to do computation and
the way you can move around within that
space is by doing these kinds of
exchanging operations okay so you still
have the same so now you can see where
the
some extra juice here which is that you
still have this topological protection
because there's no difference locally
between this state in this case but if
you take these with your Huck and flew
right away to take a skip one of these
expectations and drag it around then you
can now actually do something with the
silver space at least have one part of a
problem of not being able to do anything
is solved because you can take these
expectations and bring them around each
other okay well so the measurement
problem it's make a little less clear
but again there there's at least one
thing that you can imagine which is if
you take these two excitation then you
just fuse them okay and take these
infuse them in this gate you're
basically taking this and just refusing
it back into the vacuum this or nothing
going on there whereas over here you
take these infuse them and you are left
with an excitation that has two lines
coming out of it so you have something
left over in this case which you don't
miss case and if you have some way of
measuring that whether or not you have
something left over then you might be
able to do that measurement okay
equations are willing
yeah so um it it may or may not so one
thing I didn't particularly emphasized
here is that really you know the way
these lines are drawn I mean this is
quantum mechanics so really these lines
have some are riding around these points
with some angular momentum essentially
and so these excitations while they both
have two lines coming out of them
actually have different angle momenta so
they may have gift they may actually
have different energies so if you have
some way of distinguishing energies you
might even be able to tell which you
have I guess that also depends well may
be careful
and i think the some extent it may not
really matter in the sense that it i
think it's just a software problem
whether or not no seriously wet it may
only be important that you just don't
know it's funny sense of software
company may only be important to be able
to distinguish nothing from something
and what that something is introduces
some extra overhead but may not really
be important but again i think that it
might be possible to actually
distinguish what that something is
between these different Emeril mentum
States if you have them I mean that all
that's everly dependent on you know what
your how sophisticated measurement
technique is where then you'd rather pay
the extra overhead and measurements or
in software may be my guess is that it
will require heroic efforts to be able
to distinguish something from nothing
and so you're probably better off doing
it as much else as you can do it
software develop ever off okay so but to
give you an example for Super K equals 2
we have the surgery relation over here
now what you can see is you take lots of
articles 2 and 3 and then find them
around each other like that then in fact
because of that surgery relation of that
form you can apply it let's stay on
these three lines over here and you see
that it's actually a linear combination
of these other states so you can using
these surgery relations you can reduce
you know you can figure out what the
results that you can basically do these
computations okay that's it's
essentially these types of computations
that have been done by the system okay
similarly you can also convince yourself
that there are nine ground states on the
torus roughly corresponding to Y number
0 1 and 2 among these different
directions now I start out by discussing
these kind of caricatures for states of
matter and I said that in some sense the
definition of a topological state is
that it's low energy effective
no theory should does not need to be
written down without invoking a metric
that say it's topological invariant now
or correlation functions are topological
invariant now what I've been talking
about now Mosley's wave functions for
some specific hamiltonians which even
though we're writing them in some
abstract fashion they were really just
some particular wave functions some
particular characteristic or
representative wave functions now it's
very useful in thinking about kind of
general properties some states of matter
to look at the field theory which is not
tied down to any particular local
microscopic model ok so the associated
field theories from all these days I'm
talking about our gauge theories but
these unusual branding properties that
we're talking about when you take this
part around each other all that arises
from some generalization of the aeronaut
flow with that ok so I don't a bone
effect on our mind uses this famous
observation that you know if you put
flux magnetic flux let's say through the
through some region where particles not
allowed to go then even though the
particle never goes anywhere with this
magnet out here magnetic field is equal
to 0 but they're still in that phase
difference associated with two different
trajectories around this region ok but
in other words in quantum mechanics the
vector potential takes some real life
and it's not just the magnetic field
alone which is it up ok and so you can
see in particular as an electron goes
around the region which blocks inside it
picks up some phase it's basically a
generalization of that which gives in
these gates theory descriptions which
gives all the physics I've just been
discussing now all this physics of
curves are all this kind of pictures of
the drawing these are all related to
operators and gauge theories which are
called Wilson loop operators or in other
words of just polynomials of the
associated connections and the fact that
all the loot I was drawing here were
unoriented loops are just a feature of
ask you to wear roughly speaking it's
the fact that the fundamental
representation of a c2 is pseudo
leads to unoriented loops and in fact
there are generalizations of those
involving directed loops color blue you
know loops that carry several colors and
so on so the kind of standard or most
famous topological field theory is trans
Islands theory okay the abelian version
is for u 1 gauge field and just drop
this term over here and it's just for a
you one connection a it's a wedge da
until the turn Simon's form you
integrate that over space-time that's
the action to the system you can see it
doesn't involve the metric for non
abelian groups you could also introduced
in fact you need 24 gauge invariants
introduced an extra turn here so you can
vary this action and derive some
classical equations of motion with
fossil operations are most suggested the
curvature of this connection should
vanish now there's some important gauge
invariant operators here so gives you
very meaning is variance under the local
changes of coordinates local changes of
SU 2 coordinates in this theory and
these are basically the traces of the
whole anomalies of this connection and
the relation to everything I've been
talking about comes out of the fact that
from this action for these operators you
can derive some out some commutator
algebra which basically says and take
these operators commute them what you
end up with on the right hands or try to
commute them you end up with the right
hand side with some linear combination
these operators but on curves that
involve basically splicing together
these the two curves involved wherever
they intersect and the basic kind of
representation theory problem of
representing this algebra leads you
right back to all the structure that we
just talked about that we were that we
essentially discussed from the point of
view of generalizing the kataeb model
and get back to the same structure you
now have some up
w-which you represent on wave functions
sire beta by the following way in the
smaller kind of pictorial way by just
taking the union of whatever the
argument is here with this curve unless
your intersections and intersections are
resolved in a certain way okay and once
you put that in your in fact get back
operators w that satisfy the desired
commutation relations you of course also
as you can probably anticipate get back
all the structure that we were just
talking about if these slides ago for
instance when you take two curves which
don't intersect you can of course to
form them continuously state intersect
twice and using that resolution of
crossings you can see that these two are
in fact will give you the same thing if
and only FD satisfies the required
values okay so it's a tightly
constrained system which you can either
arrive at from this point of view that
you're trying to generalize kitchen now
k is this number that enters here in the
action and and enters the commutation
relations as well
okay so roughly speaking then we have
the following situation in which you can
describe the physics in different ways
at different like scales at the shortest
scales is just some physics of electrons
and spins at Point C of a local
Hamiltonian which is the storm of local
operators so everything is kind of 0d
physics of local interactions okay
between the two spins here and there
neighboring spins there we go to
intermediate length scales an angel
meter length scales you sort of forget
about this grainy microscopic structure
and everything is sort of 1d physics of
loops okay and then you go to the
longest length scales and then you can
even forget about loops really and it's
just maybe some degenerate ground states
on GMC surfaces or brain group
representations for quasiparticles and
it's all kind of the whole full 2d
physics is recovered at the longest line
scales now this particular way of
thinking about it actually begs the
following question which is that is
stable phase of matter it's often the
case that the intermediate length scale
physics is actually the physics of some
nearby critical point okay and it's only
the longest length scales that the order
sets in and here the intermediate length
scale physics is all this 1d physics of
curves and loops and for that physics in
fact these surgery relations are not
particularly important ok but just
invariance under continuous deformations
and the ability to shrink contractible
loops is really all you need is only at
much longer distances that the system
realizes you know an intermediate scale
system doesn't know if it's on a torus
or sphere whatever it's at longer scales
that all that visits arises and it's at
longer scales also going to lower
frequencies that you then realize that
the system has an energy gap ok when
you're intermediate scales and therefore
intermediate energy scales as well the
system the gap doesn't matter your
energies above the gap the fact that
you're on a torus doesn't matter you're
looking
scales short compared to that and so the
physics in some sense looks more like
just di saqafi which maybe the physics
of some nearby critical point and from
this point of view of imposing relation
you know one doesn't ordinarily think
about going into a phase by good life
life going to its nearby critical point
in going into the phase because after
all critical points are hard to get to
your almost never critical points but
phases occupies some finite part of the
phase diagram so it's from the usual
point of view you know if you're
interested in a particular phase the
critical point is theoretically
interesting but probably not that useful
but here it's a little bit different
because you know we're understanding its
phase as imposing certain relations and
the critical point arises by imposing
not more but fewer relations and so from
that point of view in terms of tuning in
some sense the critical point is easier
to envision
but I can think of
it's an unusual way of thinking of a
field theory an unusual way of thinking
of physical system you know in terms of
imposing conditions in this way um no
it's more like that okay so it has more
to do with an approach to a problem
rather than aprende a lying problem I
think which is that we you know we can't
solve all hamiltonians right and so
obviously the stable phase occupies a
larger part of the phase diagram and so
there's some a big region out here okay
here's a critical point million members
you know some other phases out here so
obviously it is harder to get you to get
here but in terms of soluble hamiltonian
soluble models that's really hard to get
to here because it's vaulting allowed
parameters was it may be easier to get
to something solid or at least get into
this neighborhood and then hope to be
once you hope to be in this neighborhood
then at least if you know something
about this critical point for instance
if it has well few relevant directions
then your chances of getting into the
phase you're interested in may be easier
so I think it has more to do with that
yeah so in particular so this doesn't
look of course simpler so I'm what I
bring down here is a Hamiltonian which
imposes of the relations that I showed
you earlier so out of these three
relations it imposes this isotope
invariants okay and it imposes some
business with udacity d for small
contractible loops it doesn't impose any
kind of surgery relation now this looks
considerably more complicated than to
tire small that wrote down earlier only
because what you're really doing here is
you're taking that model which is simple
in terms of some vertex and some look at
terms and the vertex terms are unchanged
they're still requiring both Luke's the
placate terms have to be mutilated to
get rid of the surgeon relations
and so it looks ugly but in fact it's
really simple okay it is simple so what
this does it implies this relation for
D&I stop you without surgery now as I
said as unlike in that case these
different terms in Hamiltonian don't
commute with each other okay however
they do have they do annihilate in fact
the same ground state wave function as
for guitar tomorrow okay because it does
to samis fear or some surface with
trivial topology precisely because as
long as you're not worried about winding
numbers then I so copy and dear all you
need and the ground state is just the
sum over all configurations with instead
of equal amplitude as an amplitude e to
the number of loops and this can now be
interpreted as in the case of the stable
phases also as a topological oh sorry
has a loop gas with some figure skating
d squared because if you take this norm
square at the wave function it looks
just like the partition function of the
OM loot model where n is d squared and
let me just remind you this loot model
is basically some way of it's sort of an
analytic continuation the following if
you think of a model of om spins so
spins pointing on s n minus 1 then I for
e to the minus beta age if you write
down this funny-looking thing over here
and expand it in powers of X then you
get an expansion of loops which loops
are correspond to all the places where
you've chosen this term ride in this
term an expansion of this product and
you get x over N to the length of loop
times and to the number of loops and
whereas this is only well defined for an
integer this is pretty well defined for
n naught engineer as well and so one
could instead take this is the
definition of the model okay call it
instead of the OM model of court Oh F
move model and that model is exactly
soluble and so that statistical
mechanics information tell
at least about some ground state
information in this quantum mechanical
problem okay so first of all it's uh
it's not by any means difficult that two
plus 1 dimensional quantum mechanical
problems will have a ground state which
has a simple interpretation in terms of
a two plus zero dimensional system
mechanic model but this is an example of
that another well-known example is
Lachlan's wave function in the quantum
Hall effect its norm square is a
classical plasma in two dimensions so
okay so using this student announced
otisco mechanics these models we can
immediately derive some ground state
property so for instance we know that
loops the end or over long distances
determined by some exponents which can
be obtained as a function of n this is
all in the low temperature phase of this
model and in fact you go to the zero
temperature limit it's actually
basically the same thing as the FK
representation of not low temperature
but critical Q equals N squared State
pasa model which actually has the same
exponents so while it was kind of more
natural in terms of models we're talking
about to think of it in terms of these
owen loop models you may wish to think
of in terms of pots models instead which
i have the same exponents okay but it's
not but I should emphasize its critical
parts and low temperature Oh n-now the
ground state as I said of this model
contains these long loops characterized
by exponents so long as DS less than
equal to square root of two now these
are all rising in correlators which in
terms of the underlying spins are
non-local right because you're referring
to things on the same loop where these
pins remember these things are just sort
of these loops are just where you have
you up spins and so it doesn't really
care whether and if you're computing a
in the quantum problem a spin spin
correlation function
character on the same loop or not and so
these correlation functions of the
quantum problem you know the two spins
are in fact uncorrelated and have
correlation length 0 basically so
correlation functions of local operators
have correlation like zero but there are
these non local operators which have to
do with fins on the same loop that have
power laws associated with them so
there's this quasi topological kind of
flavor flavor to this debate in the
ground state local operators have this
kind of topological flavor that you know
basically they have correlation 10 but
then there are these non local operators
which you can define which have power
laws associated with them now you might
think well ok it's probably true in any
wave function that if you cook up a
crazy enough operator that's not locally
defined in terms of the underlying
degrees of freedom that it's likely to
have power laws associated with the
right i mean if you if you work hard
enough that's true but i think that here
there's something there's some real meat
behind it and it's because the
meandering of these loops actually is
late the fact that there are low energy
excitations in this model which are but
they all go in general is if there's no
gap and so what you can do is write down
a trial wave function where instead of
just get this is a variational argument
that's not about the present yeah yeah
so so yeah so when I say trial wave
function let's try this wave function
and check and see if it's if it has a
gap or not ok so it's obviously is much
harder to prove that you have a gap the
gap lessness you get lucky with a gas
you're in good shape so instead of just
taking every consideration weighted by V
to the number of loops you take a wave
function so that would be just the just
the ground state but you now make the
wave function change sign depending on
whether you have configurations which
are which have loops which are long or
configurations which only have
loops in them and you say you're going
to make this precise what you mean by
long it's not particularly important for
I'm about to say so there is some way of
making precise with x and y are here and
since this model is critical we can we
can certainly define long so the
probability of a configuration having a
long loop is one-half say okay and
plates one half that means that the
overlap between this wave function in
the ground state is going to be zero so
it's a log onto the ground state and
furthermore you can see that you can
check that the Hamiltonian has
expectation value which goes is an
inverse power of the length in the large
size limit and therefore the gap
vanishes okay so basically the state
space kind of breaks up in this way into
state configurations with large loops
and those which don't you have a wave
function of those from 1 to minus 1 and
basically because the Hamiltonian isn't
connecting these two parts the
Hamiltonian basically doesn't
distinguish the difference between
Taiwan loops are 0 in some sense right
the Hamiltonian isn't really very
sensitive the only part that you're
really worried about is this part where
this gradient here and the Hamiltonian
is not very sensitive to that so in fact
and all of these models that you wrote
down are actually a critical on
parametrized by D ok so that's unusual
because we know in two dimensions we
have we have critical lines but outside
of two dimensions we don't really have
any examples here is this example which
in some way is boosting two dimensional
physics into three dimensions okay but
also has much three dimensional physics
of its own so okay so we also were
interested in what the low energy
effective field theory is for this
critical line and again we can address
all kinds of questions if we have this
low energy field theory but it has some
unusual properties first of all that
Omega goes is K square which
from that gap lessness proof you can use
secondly a reasonable guy sure that this
also should be an su to gauge scaring
since this is the structure you've been
discussing but also this theory has to
have some real juice to it because there
are non-trivial exponents associated
with some rum with some non local
operators but at the same time local
operators should be short range okay so
those first two requirements motivate
the following gas which is a non abelian
gauge theory if this term work if this
derivative weren't here this would be
what you call you and Mills theory but
we've essentially put in some extra
derivatives into yang yang mill story
would give your mega doses k okay which
is bad but the second thing where's
yang-mills story would give which is bad
as this is a non-trivial in tracking
theory even though it's kind of hidden
in here because it's be defined in terms
of the underlying gauge field V is base
for the spatial component the time
component either of the curvature ok and
so well it's a fact of one of the duo
the curvature I guess so that's a
nonlinear thing so this is actually
known than your theory and in the
yang-mills case we know that this
nonlinear theory is strongly interacting
with that is not critical at all it's a
confinement theory as a mascot even
though naively a tree level it looks
like the critical theory so we had to
make some modification to stand again
Mills good now there's still a question
which is that although this theory again
is naively critical that's the stakes
critical tree level and in fact the
interactions are marginal you may ask
whether this interacting theory is
absolutely critical we're gonna have a
full solution to this question but at
one loop one can check that the coupling
constant actually has vanishing beta
function at one loop so if that survives
to higher orders then this theory is
also critical and that lens
oh right yeah so right well okay so idea
in yang-mills theory a tree level is
critical instead of eigen has the second
derivative is critical but then if you
consider the interactions just by power
counting the interactions relevant okay
so it's a given that strongly
interacting and then you can also show
those strong interactions lead you to
that face no no no I mean okay so I
haven't done the calculation I don't
have a proof that it's 02 all orders
there's something that's suggestive here
which is that actually and a which are
the conjugate variables appear in many
ways on equal footing with the second
derivatives here and really hear the
second derivatives of a so there's
almost an EI du out if you had a truly a
duality then it would be clear because
Ian a really come with g + 1 over G
scaled in the most natural way so there
isn't quite the duality that would make
this a slam dunk but there is some
flavor of it and it may be that with a
clever gauge choice which wasn't the
right gate choice to do this one move
graduation but some other clever gauge
choice you might be able to show that
innocent engages thirties of duality
approves it so I mean I don't have a
full solution but my guess is that this
isn't just a coincidence or the
advantages at one loop and then
advantages the our loops as well and if
that's true then it's telling you that
this beer is also in a critical line and
that is very tempting just to say that
you since we knew about 0 critical lines
and three dimensions previously and now
we found two of them which have some
similarities maybe chances are they're
the same thing so that's a tempting
conjecture to make some further
observations that I keep orgy small
there's some additional perturbations
you can add which have run away flows
and that presumably corresponds to
large decays wendys that should be
square wendy's greater than equal to
square root 2 which is basically like
some classical limit which is massive as
in the queue state pots and all those
and om bowls so just to wrap up quickly
then there's this sort of pictorial
comment oral descriptions topological
phases there are many open questions as
one would like to address so this kind
of took us on this tour through
electrons topology stat mech gauge
theories and so on but very little to
say about computer science and since I'm
here to software company I should should
probably should have said something but
you know the goal is that here is that
by understanding more about certain
types of condensed matter systems that
we could then have some kind of platform
or arena where one can do quantum
computation and you know those are those
basic problems still not understood in
many ways so you know this pictorial
representation motivates certain types
of microscopic model so it's like this
thing I was saying here we have some
ideas about soluble models here but
really in the end of the day you want to
understand more about the holistic
models the kinds of things that
experimental see in their systems or
might be able to engineer and so you
really would like to perturb away from
soluble models towards a more realistic
ones you know part of that problem may
be related to this problem of whether
it's kind of easier to get close to a
critical point and assume that they're
just relatively few relevant
perturbations or whether you need to
somehow both these Jones mental
relations and in kind of a more precise
way the latter situation would obviously
bad it which is related again to the
stability of this critical line and so
I'd like to just finish up by mentioning
a few references because i didn't put in
the references whatsoever and the body
of the talk there's a lot of
foundational work here on the basic
ideas of quantum computation and also
many basic ideas about topological field
theories and the like a couple of papers
by us and some other people on how you
can motivate some microscopic models
from these ideas and some related
quantum critical points and some things
on that make a fuss to look thank you
very much
you